bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur france 3
normandie dans cette voie est libre une
émission spéciale d'une heure consacrée
aux enjeux des élections régionales des
6 et 13 décembre prochains
bonjour physique vous dès aujourd'hui
pour aller aujourd'hui d'économie de
l'emploi bien sûr d'aménagement du
territoire et des transports du ciel
ensemble alors il ya dans son cas une
ville un peu jaillir un peu symbolique
de notre région il se passe beaucoup de
choses le président sortant ni
départements de la basse normandie nous
disais tout à l'heure que le département
de l'orne était très industrielle on le
voit ici à lens ont alors la halle aux
toiles d'alençon qui dont la première
pierre a été lancée en 1827 par marie
thérèse de france qui n'est autre que la
fille de louis saez depuis la république
s'est installé est bien installée et
parmi les symboles de la république il
ya la démocratie et parler d'économie
c'est très important surtout dans cette
campagne électorale
si vous avez comme moi et j'en sais je
sais que vous l'avez fait regarder
toutes les professions de foi
pratiquement les deux tiers de ce que je
trouve dans ces professions de foi et
ben part d'économie et surtout d'emploi
et c'est vrai qu'en ce moment ballan
fois qu'ils se portent pas très bien
effectivement est tout à fait
d'actualité dans cette campagne
électorale
fini la campagne régionale reprend
doucement dans un contexte très
particulier
oui seulement qu'on puisse dire vous
vous souvenez sur téléspectateurs la
semaine dernière nous avions consacré
une émission justement à la prêtresse de
vent mais aura eu avant il ya revu après
et c'est vrai que l'ambiance c'est un
petit peu tendu et d'une certaine façon
on peut dire que la campagne électorale
a été quelques peu escales beauté mais
pas complètement supprimée parce que la
démocratie la sens de la démocratie
c'est cela aussi
et puis c'est pas parce que des
nihilistes absolument varden imposer la
démocratie qu'elle n'existe plus et bien
qu'elle va se laisser faire et c'est le
sens de l'émission d'aujourd'hui avec
nous aux cinq invités politiques lors
mauvais l'actuel président socialiste de
la région basse normandie et candidat
tête de liste pour le département de
l'orne
bonjour et bienvenue sans vous êtes vice
président sortant du conseil régional de
haute normandie vous êtes numéro un sur
la liste d'europe écologie les verts
dans le département mais son but de
l'écologie jean chatelais actuel
président
du groupe communiste conseil régional de
basse normandie et tête de liste front
de gauche pour le département de l'orne
bonjour sophie gaugain vous êtes donc mr
les républicains de de vue les vous êtes
également conseiller régional sortant du
conseil régional de basse-normandie et
vous êtes numéro 2 donc sur la liste
dans le département du calvados sa liste
d'union de la droite et du centre
partout des moindres watts ont pu de
timothée houssin vous êtes secrétaire
départemental du front national dans le
département de l'eure et tête de liste
frontiste pour ce même département et
bien sûr à vos côté emmanuel chaunu qui
via ses dessins de presse en direct nous
apportera son regard sur ce débat oui le
président hollande s'est transformé en
dieu janus
en même temps ils pansent les plaies de
la république et il mène le combat en
syrie ça va être compliqué merci
emmanuel on vous retrouve tout au long
de cette émission alors à deux les
normandies sauront-elles plus forte
comment allier leurs atouts pallier
leurs faiblesses
avant de lancer le débat voyons le
visage de cette future grande normandie
d'après vue économique
avec ce reportage de marc moiroud
bissielo avec 3,3 millions d'habitants
la future grande normandie se hisse à la
neuvième place des régions françaises
mais aggrave au cinquième rang lorsqu'on
s'intéresse au pib par habitant avec 27
milles 180 euros toutefois le revenu
moyen normes en 1601 euros par mois est
légèrement inférieur à la moyenne
française
elle affiche un taux de chômage de 10,2
pour cent supérieur de 0,3 point à la
moyenne nationale
273 1700 normands sont à la recherche
d'un emploi la normandie présente la
dette la plus faible par habitant 161
euros ce qui offre de belles marges
la fusion de la basse-normandie plutôt
rurale avec la haute-normandie plus
industrialisés va offrir un meilleur
équilibre à la grande région
ces 600 km de côtes offre un beau
potentiel touristique et économique
la normandie possède d'ailleurs le
deuxième port du pays avec le havre elle
est très ouverte sur l'international
avec plus du tiers de son pib consacré à
l'export la population normande est
plutôt jeune avec 30 7% de moins de 25
ans des jeunes qui réussissent un peu
moins bien au bac que dans le reste du
pays
87,6 % de reçus en 2014
c'est 0 7 point de moins que la moyenne
française enfin si avec la réunification
la normandie s'installe dans le top 5
des régions françaises d'un point de vue
économique elle reste inexistante au
niveau européen
seule l'île de france et rhône alpes
auvergne se trouve dans les dix
premières régions du vieux continent
classement dominé par les länder
allemands alors philippe à l'économie
c'est le gros dossier entre les mains de
la région elle pouvoir encore accrue
depuis l'été dernier avec la loi notre
la nouvelle organisation des territoires
de la république alors absolue on va
avoir l'occasion de lyon au cours de
l'émission d'y revenir le savoir
notamment comment va s'organiser
cette région qui va aller où
heureusement bien sûr des services
publics mais pas seulement
alors c'est vrai vous avez raison la
région d'une manière générale va voir
ses compétences
conforté dans tout ce qui est
accompagnement des actions et que
l'amicale or ne serait ce que pour aider
les entreprises ne serait-ce qu'au
niveau de la formation parce que parfois
on a un petit peu trop tendance à
oublier que la formation est
parfaitement dépendante de l'industrie
l'industrie de la formation et ce serait
une erreur de ne pas tenir compte d'un
non sens qui se veut de plus en plus
cohérent alors la difficulté
ou bien de l'entendre va être bien
évidemment de poursuivre dans cette
direction c'est à dire aider l'industrie
et de l'économie et des la formation à
aller plus loin alors c'est vrai que la
région est peu endettée certains disent
elles m'ont peut-être d'ambition c'est
un des sens du débat d'aujourd'hui
alors justement comme on dit et dans les
bulletins scolaires dans la vie dans le
reportage la normandie à un très beau
potentiel comment l'améliorer comment
surtout créer des emplois on l'a vu le
taux de chômage en normandie 10,2 pour
cent est un peu au dessus de la moyenne
nationale laurent beauvais il faut
soutenir d'abord les filières important
qui porte l'essentiel de l'emploi il
faut aider les secteurs qui émergent qui
apparaissent on a le secteur des
énergies marines renouvelables faut
fixer des orientations claires c'est de
l'argent public
la formation le développement durable
l'aménagement du territoire
l'innovation technologique et puis les
dispositifs que nous avons
contrairement à certaines propositions
qui consistent à tout revoir on les
utilise de façon pragmatique de façon
simple et immédiate est à l'ecoute
l'expérience que j'ai de cette
responsabilité ne monte que être à
l'écouté travailler collectif auprès des
entreprises
c'est le gage du succès alors maintenant
aux marges de manoeuvres ne sont pas
énormes on parle de la rti pp régionales
c'est vrai qu'au niveau de l'impôt et en
plus vous ne voulez pas augmenter
l'impôt si vous regardez bien votre
programme
sauf on n'a pas d'importance non mais je
veux dire en l'occurrence ne voulait pas
que la pression fiscale manière générale
je pense à l'atp mais globalement bon
c'est pas vraiment évident et puis
deuxièmement au niveau des entreprises
comment pouvez-vous les aider alors que
votre marge de manoeuvre n'est pas quand
même excessivement large
nous avons des moyens nous avons mis en
place des fonds avec des partenariats la
bpi les moyens il existe c'est la façon
de les utiliser la réactivité je le
disais et l'orientation générale le sens
à donner je voulais dit tout à l'heure
c'est très important de conditionner ses
aides à des orientations façon à ce que
les citoyens comprennent comment nous
aidons ces entreprises sophie gaugain
entre la normandie est assez plus rien
il ya de l'agroalimentaire notamment
bassement
agriculture il ya beaucoup d'industries
ça va de la pharmacie l'aéronautique le
secteur automobile et des secteurs qui
vont bien avec d'autres qui vont moins
bien qu'il faudra accompagner
comment est ce que est ce que l'union
fait vraiment la force je crois à
condition qu'on s'en donne les moyens et
contrairement à ce que je viens
d'entendre qu'on change les logiciels de
réflexion en matière économique il ya
urgence vous l'avez dit la présentation
qui est faite le démontre et je crois
que le projet que nous portons avec
hervé morin et la normandie conquérante
c'est ça c'est enfin avoir une nouvelle
stratégie économique au service des
entreprises et de l'emploi des normands
ça passe par quoi agir sur tous les
leviers en même temps on peut plus se
permettre d'attendre ça fait dix ans
aujourd'hui qu'on attend avec les
résultats qu'on connaît
agir sur trois leviers primordiaux vous
l'avez évoqué c'est d'abord la stratégie
la fierté date normand ce qui va bien le
valoriser le faire évoluer et le pousser
et puis ce qui est émergent aider à la
recherche au développement
c'est la marque made in normandie s'en
servir comme un levier au niveau
français mais aussi vous l'avez dit
l'européen c'est ça l'enjeu est aussi de
la nouvelle région
et puis c'est se mettre à disposition
des entreprises est un facilitateur
facilitateur quand ça va bien et
réacteurs quand ça va mal facilitateur
avec une agence unique doté d'1 5
million d'euros qui permet d'intervenir
à différents stades du développement de
l'entreprise
et puis facilitateur sur les délais de
traitement aujourd'hui quand ça va mal
il faut aller très vite et quand ça va
bien il faut les pousser ces entreprises
en termes de compétitivité sur le
territoire national c'est donc réduire
les délais et aider les entreprises dans
toutes les démarches administratives
c'est une agence pour aller plus vite
pour aller plus loin c'est aussi le fait
de mettre le paquet sur des secteurs
entiers de l'économie
je parle aussi pour le calvados mais ça
vaut sur les l'ensemble de la normandie
et de la france le btp va mal il ya des
plans d'urgence qui sont proposés dans
notre projet particulièrement en
utilisant
le développement durable et les
nouvelles techniques de bâtiment alors
en même temps par mail moi je
m'interromps mais c'est vrai la baule
bien que globalement à l'échelle de la
france les collectivités territoriales
investissent moins et c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles le chômage
augmente on ne peut pas dire le
contraire
alors vous parlais tout à l'heure d'un
guichet unique était cher d'ailleurs à
votre collègue monsieur le vern le
président du conseil régional de haute
normandie
mais c'est pas obligatoirement ou si
évident que ça ça fait quand même des
années que l'échec est patent sur le
plan d'emploi oui mais excusez moi on
n'est pas aux responsabilités depuis des
années ça fait 11 ans basse tandis que
les socialistes sont en responsabilité
17 ans en haute normandie donc moi je ne
porte pas ce bilan nous ce que nous
voulons proposer c'est écrire une
nouvelle page blanche au service de
l'économie et avec une nouvelle manière
de gouverner c'est à dire décider des
politiques régionales avec les chefs
d'entreprise que justement les dossiers
qu'ils soient soumis à la région pour
les aider soit examiné avec le c'est
quand même eux qui savent faire les
choses et qu'on ne soit pas dans une
technostructure qui nous fasse perdre du
temps et de l'énergie pour eux c'est
l'emploi des normands derrière et vous
l'avez dit que nous avons des filières
d'excellence mais aussi plein de choses
qui émergent
il faut aider la recherche et
développement timothée houssen question
internet de crise marie le dicton dit
l'union fait la force maintenant reste à
savoir comment sera fait cette
réunification aurons nous plus de moyens
toutes les villes de cette nouvelle
région seront elle représentait quels
sont les avantages
tout d'abord nous ce qui nous semble
important c'est que la région fasse
aussi un certain nombre d'économies par
exemple sur ses dépenses de
fonctionnement pour voir réorienter ce
budget nous nous pensons que le budget
qui est dédié à l'aide et économique
doit être augmentée par le biais
d'économies faites par ailleurs comme ça
on n'a pas à augmenter les impôts quand
on constate par exemple que des
entreprises ont reçu des aides publiques
ne respectent pas leur contrat ça peut
être le cas de schneider electric par
exemple accueilli qui touchent des
publics qui malgré tout délocalisent
quand on constate que des entreprises
comme schering ploug à hérouville touche
également des aides publiques et malgré
de forts bénéfices tu licencient
massivement
nous nous pensons que les aides
notamment de la région ne sont pas
utilisés à bon escient
nous pensons qu'on devrait les donner en
priorité notamment aux tpe et aux pme
avant tout sur des critères de création
d'emplois le rôle également de la région
ça serait de donner et de prêter surtout
un certain nombre de fonds aux
entreprises qui ont des problèmes de
trésorerie on voit en normandie
énormément d'entreprises qui vont bien
qu'ils sont en bonne santé qui sont un
modèle qui marche mais qui auront des
difficultés de trésorerie et qui ont du
mal à se financer auprès des banques ça
peut être quelque chose que la région
peut faire et puis il faut aussi donner
priorité à des secteurs qui demain
seront des secteurs d'avenir
on peut par exemple penser au biogaz à
la méthanisation opposait pensez
également à tout ce qui est
démantèlement de navires
on sait qu'il ya une âme de bateaux de
plaisance de pêche même de guerre en
france qui attendait d'être démantelé
et on pourrait par exemple créer une
filière dans ce domaine qui pourrait
créer beaucoup d'emplois
dans ce cadre-là la région doit être
stratège et aider à la création
d'emplois que de taleb vous ça vous
prenez voit un ultime pour créer cent
mille emplois non délocalisables
ça rejoint un petit peu ce que dit ti
meute et où ils s'emmerdent croissance
et d'emploi non mais dans terme non
délocalisables je vous remercie
l'organiser débat comme sur ce sujet qui
est difficile de rester sur l'emploi
mais qui en effet la préoccupation
essentielle principal on va dire de nos
concitoyens aujourd'hui si on prend un
peu de recul on se rend compte
madame que depuis rien rien n'a beaucoup
changé depuis maintenant presque 40 ans
on oscille entre 8 et 12 % de chômage
qui dans tous les cas n'est pas
satisfaisant et donc nous ce dont on
soit ce qu'on souhaiterait convaincre la
prochaine saison souhaiterait convaincre
la prochaine assemblée régionale
ces défaites qu'on peut pas se contenter
de faire un peu mieux un peu plus de
simplifier l'accès aux aides de de mieux
placer les gens sur le marché du travail
tel qu'il est mais qu'il faut
complètement revoir les choses qu'il
faut toute l'attention qu'elle soit
c'est donc c'est en effet à new deal
économique écologique que nous que nous
proposons en complément des actions qui
reste indispensable de l'état mais aussi
d'action qui dépend de décisions
internationales rappelons le quand même
nous pensons que la région en faisant sa
part peut fortement développer des
emplois des emplois locaux des emplois
non délocalisables trois items une
région qui serait exemplaire et
solidaire une région qui ferait
massivement le pari de l'économie verte
est une région qui se mobilisera pour
accompagner la création d emplois du 21e
siècle
donc je pourrais vous donner des
exemples dans chacun sur chacun de ces
sites
mais si vous le permettez ça me paraît
assez important avant une chose quand
même dans votre programme qui va un peu
surpris vous vous les accompagnez les 32
heures sur 4 jours
alors si vous êtes le seul d'ailleurs je
devais quand design poser cette question
c'est laisser le premier ritaine une
région exemplaire et solidaire c'est une
région qui soutiendra massivement
l'économie solidaire dont je rappelle
qu'elle est plus robuste
1 les scop aujourd'hui sont plus
robustes que la plus majorité des tpe
pme
c'est aussi une région qui n'auraient
pas peur en effet d'accompagner les
entreprises qui expérimenterait des
accords de réduction du temps de travail
on pense qu'il faut reprendre la
question des 32 heures
le deuxième thème dont je souhaite
parler un concerne la transition
énergétique et écologique vous ne serais
pas surpris on pense qu'il ya trente
mille emplois il ya trente mille emplois
à la clé
si on décide de rénover quarante mille
logements par an si on décide d'aller
sur un scénario 100 % d'électricité
renouvelables en 2050 on s'y met
maintenant on va créer trente mille
emplois voilà des questions sur
lesquelles on pense que la région veut
faire efficacement effet levier le
châtelet justement concernant l'emploi
alors vous vous avez un slogan quand
même si un vent de colère un souffle
d'espoir je dis pas que ça résume bon
vos thèses économiques concernant cette
campagne électorale pour la jeanne mais
vous êtes un peu en colère quand même
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire tout à
fait en colère notamment sur le sur la
question de l'emploi ont manifestement
beaucoup d'attention mais tout le monde
ne joue pas le jeu
à commencer par le patronat et le
gouvernement il faut bien le reconnaître
puisque au travers du cic eux ce sont
des sommes considérables qui viennent
dans chaque entreprise 6% de la masse
salariale et on s'aperçoit que ça n'a
strictement aucun effet sur l'évolution
de l'emploi
on pourrait penser et en bon normand que
6 % confié au patronat ça pourrait faire
6 % d'emplois en plus et bien non pas du
tout et c'est bien souvent même le
contraire nous continuons à voir des
délocalisations avec des entreprises qui
touchent des sommes phénoménales en cce
alors il faut travailler ces questions
c'est pour ça que nous appelons à une
mobilisation générale mais quand ils ont
nous disons général ce n'est pas que le
patronat il faut que les travailleurs
aussi soit saisie de ces questions
puissent en débattre et puissent eux
aussi faire des propositions sur toutes
les filières normande et les finir
normand de volaille et
indiqué sont nombreuses il y en a à
développer il y en a surtout à conserver
absolument nous sommes un département
est ici très industrielle vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure si cette faible
compétitivité effectivement des pôles
d'excellence vie tout à fait et
notamment sur fley région de flers que
je représente ici puisque je suis fait
rien sur lequel il ya le pôle qui
s'appelle le ciriam qui est la pôle
mondial de l'automobile et qui a été
développée on peut lire très fortement
par la région 1 qui a mis un énorme
effort en créant aussi une école
d'ingénieurs au tour c'était on a pensé
aussi à cette recherche industrielle
donc la région n'a pas rien fait mais
c'est vrai que sur le secteur des
subventions nous sommes maintenant ici
en basse normandie sur des années re
donc c'est pas d'argent perdu
l'entreprise le doigt et l'or en bourse
et il est vrai qu'il faut arrêter c'est
ce que fait malheureusement le
gouvernement de donner de l'argent sans
engagement préel sur des créations
d'emplois je m'en parle de l'emploi on
va parler de la formation le talon
d'achille de la normandie c'est
peut-être le faible taux de
qualification de ses habitants 66 % ont
un niveau de formation inférieur au
baccalauréat
parmi les 20 24 ans un jeune sur cinq
n'a aucun diplôme
des efforts sont donc amenés pour lutter
contre l'échec scolaire le décrochage la
fuite des cerveaux et pour rendre la
formation professionnelle attractive car
ces domaines appartiennent aussi à la
région veiller sur reportage d'alexandre
résultats à quoi pensent les jeunes
normands quand on leur parle d'études
après le bac une question qu'ils
abordent sans tabou quitter la normandie
semble pour eux une évidence l'optique
d'aller à paris ou d'aller dans une
grande ville
je sais pas c'est plus vaste on a plus
de possibilités de rencontres et de jeux
c'est lui même il ya plus de valeur
d'aller dans une grande école parisienne
que de rester en normandie sur combat
y'a pas grand chose puis je pense que si
c'est bien de s'éloigner de chez soi un
petit peu et à prendre son envol
alors comment rendre plus attractive la
vie au lycée et développer l'attachement
à la région
la droite d'hervé morin veut initier la
bourse au mérite
à gauche on en parle aussi autre
proposition que l'on retrouve dans les
deux listes améliorer le cadre au
quotidien en implantant le wifi dans les
établissements et les internes armes
mais est ce suffisant
le syndicat des enseignants le snes fait
l'amour en épluchant les programmes ça
m'a l'air d'être d'apparaître comme une
priorité effectivement mais globalement
parce que quand vous regardez si vous
faites une simple recherche sur internet
des programmes des diverses candidats la
première chose qu'ils vont mettre en
avant c'est la mobilisation économique
c'est vrai qu'il ya une partie des
électeurs qui se pose forcément des
questions d'économie mais ce qu'ils ne
voient pas c'est le lien qu'il peut y
avoir avec l'éducation de leurs propres
enfants
voilà et ça c'est ça c'est grave de la
part d'élus de ne pas faire le lien avec
le monde et de l'éducation tel qu'il est
actuellement
ça c'est une vraie c'est un vrai
problème et quand ce n'est pas
l'économie qui vient parasiter le propos
c'est la sécurité qui prend le dessus
le front national promet une seule
mesure pour les lycées la
vidéosurveillance alors la normandie at
elle un problème avec ces jeunes
le monde universitaire attend beaucoup
également des fonds régionaux
le pôle universitaire caen rouen réuni
plus de 50 mille étudiants auxquels il
faut ajouter l'université du havre et
ses formations spécifiques orientés sur
le maritime et le commerce international
une seule université à terme c'est l'un
des objectifs mais le quotidien des
étudiants c'est aussi une paupérisation
qui progresse avec des aides de l'état
requis 10 minutes
les candidats en campagne met l'accent
sur les efforts à faire dans un autre
domaine la formation professionnelle un
chantier immense pour adapter l'offre à
la demande des entreprises artisans et
pme ont souvent tiré la sonnette
d'alarmé ces dernières années et à
gauche comme à droite on s'engage à
aider les employeurs et les apprentis de
plus de 18 ans un levier pour lutter
contre le chômage des jeunes qui est en
normandie au dessus de la moyenne
nationale
timothée houssin alors il ya beaucoup de
jeunes en normandie il y en a peu de
diplômés et quand il ya des cerveaux
beaucoup vont voir ailleurs ce qu'il
peut être plutôt sain mais on a du mal
aussi à à capter des serveurs que vous
proposez front national je pense que ça
va aussi dans les deux sens il faut bien
voir que dans la région près de la
moitié des habitants ne viennent pas de
la région à l'origine donc il ya aussi
un échange moi ce sera quoi je voulais
revenir c'est sur les chiffres du
chômage ont évoqué tout à l'heure il
faut bien dire qu'on en demande il ya
aussi une particularité c'est que les
jeunes sont particulièrement touchés par
le chômage et que le nombre de personnes
parmi ces chômeurs qui sont des chômeurs
de longue durée est particulièrement
élevé puisqu'il y en a 40 7%
donc est ce qu'on constate c'est que ces
jeunes et ces personnes qui ne
retrouvent pas d'emploi n'ont
malheureusement pas une formation qui
est en adéquation avec les attentes du
marché du travail et notamment des
entreprises
nous nous souhaitons en fait créé un
observatoire de l'emploi dans la région
normandie qui permettraient de savoir ce
dont ont besoin les entreprises
notamment les entreprises innovantes
pour créer par le biais de la région les
formations qui permettront aux jeunes
demain et aux personnes qui sont
actuellement sans emploi d'avoir une
formation qui corresponde à ce
qu'attendent les entreprises
je crois par exemple qu'on a besoin de
vous le disiez tout à l'heure de
beaucoup de soudeur dans la région
voilà une formation sur lequel on
pourrait mettre l'accent il ya une
formation lycées mais injustement
alençon depuis la rentrée dernière et on
sait qu'il manque en france 1500 soudeur
alors peut-être qu'il ya un problème de
recrutement est ce que c'est le cas mais
on parlait tout à l'heure de dd longues
études
un peut-être aussi qu'il faut
revaloriser un certain nombre de métiers
manuels dans lesquels on cherche des
employés notamment via le biais de
l'apprentissage
le nombre d'apprentis et c'est le bilan
des socialistes a fortement diminué dans
la région ces cinq dernières années nous
souhaitons leur mettre en avant à la
fois auprès des entreprises pour les
aider à embaucher des entreprises à des
apprentis et faciliter notamment tout le
côté administratif pour le faire et puis
peut-être revaloriser l'apprentissage
notamment auprès des familles qui freine
parfois les jeunes à se diriger vers
l'apprentissage
alors qu'en même temps monsieur le
président ce qu'il faut pas anticiper ce
que vous faites d'ailleurs d'une
certaine façon avec l'éolien mais
peut-être davantage je ne sais pas
répondre à cette question quand on voit
par exemple la formation plus exactement
la préparation aux futures fondations
ont vu des métiers qui concerneront
l'installation l'entretien des éoliennes
c'est vrai que c'est un secteur d'avenir
qui concerne autant la bascule haletant
lundi donc toute la normandie dans son
ensemble qui vont pas aller encore un
petit peu plus loin en prévoyant
davantage des formations à venir pour
des métiers à venir ni les images on a
vu afpa cherbourg c'est ça justement il
ya plein de clichés quelques erreurs
dans le reportage c'est plus de 90 mille
étudiants que nous avons sur ce
territoire et il faut pas quand même
allé donner l'impression que tout le
monde part qui a rien la carte des
formations est très riche du lycée
jusqu'à l'université les écoles
d'ingénieurs les centres de formation on
a une carte des formations très riche
vous avez entendu certains jeunes ils
ont envie d'aller extérieur pour
d'autres raisons
dans les grandes villes est-ce qu'il
faut bien expliquer ces coquins via
nabili à un des problèmes qu'on
rencontre que vous évoquez c'est le goût
pour certains métiers le goût pour
certaines formations industrielles la
culture évolue et nous devons faire en
sorte que l'appétit pour des formations
industrielles notamment vous évoquez les
formations de soudure qui existent ici
au lycée messin alençon soit bien
compris par les familles elles mêmes
alors les enfants et maintenir des
emplois derrière et donc l'effort que
nous faisons avec l'ensemble du corps de
la formation c'est de donner des
informations sur les métiers de laisser
à comprendre qu'il ya des opportunités
les em air demain c'est pas le métier
mrc des métiers industrie
derrière c'est le sens de l'action que
nous menons et que je crois qu'il faut
continuer et amplifier à l'échelle de la
normandie on a un potentiel énorme que
la carte des formations qu'elle soit
riche c'est un constat mais surtout
c'est qu'elle doit être adaptée aux
besoins du territoire par bassin
d'emploi et bassins de vie et aux
besoins des entreprises et en même temps
des jeunes comme il ya des passions
justement je crois qu'il faut beaucoup
plus de souplesse dans les dispositifs
existants dont on voit bien aujourd'hui
l'échec les contrats d'engagement sur
l'apprentissage par exemple c'était
12500 apprentis aujourd'hui on est à
9500 s'est passé pas satisfaisant il n'y
a pas que l'apprentissage il ya aussi
l'enseignement général et l'enseignement
supérieur pour être souple il faut
travailler par bassin d'emploi en lien
avec les branches professionnelles et
utiliser l'existant
à un moment donné le besoin d'une
entreprise peut être sur tel ou tel
métier en ce moment nous visitons comme
depuis cinq ans beaucoup d'entrepreneurs
sur une chaîne de développement ils
peuvent avoir besoin de tel métier telle
qualification il faut qu'on utilise les
lycées existants ou les plateaux
techniques existants au plus près du
terrain et c'est ce qu'attendent aussi
les jeunes et leurs familles parce
qu'elle problème du coût de la vie
derrière par rapport aux apprentis ou
bien même le coût de la vie étudiante et
nous aurons là aussi tout un travail à
faire et l'université north monde doit
retrouver ses lettres de noblesse nous
avons énormément de fil hier à imaginer
que ce soit en agroalimentaire la
filière équine aussi peut faire l'objet
de programmes et travailler avec
l'europe
l'angle est primordial quel que soit
d'ailleurs l'orientation professionnelle
comprends et je crois que les jeunes
normands m la région et il faut leur
redonner confiance et est en vie et ils
reviennent voile alors toujours cette
image de la normandie que vous évoquiez
tout à l'heure c'est à dire également
l'environnement des formations s'étaient
qu'il faut aussi avoir envie de rester
c'est à l'aide
on peut dire que la coordination entre
les universités de caen du havre et
or on n'a pas hyper bien fonctionné
enfin pas en tout cas d'après les
spécialistes qui le disent aussi bien
que ça aurait pu le faire
est ce qu'il faut aller dans cette
direction et comment on peut faire en
sorte que les choses soient plus
cohérentes
sans doute mais si vous permettez je
voulais aussi réagir à votre reportage
en disant qu'on a effectivement des
jeunes qui se projette ailleurs on a
aussi des jeunes il faut pas les oublier
ceux là qui ont beaucoup de mal à sortir
de territoire géographique mais même
j'ai envie de dire culturel territoriaux
qui sont enclavés et il faut répondre
aux deux il faut s'occuper des deux donc
ce qui moi je pense que en effet ceux
qui aspirent à à bouger et danser très
bien je pense qu'il faut encourager on
est favorable nous y compris à mettre en
place des aides à la mobilité
internationale de manière conséquente
chaque année c'est des choses qui sont
possibles et ces jeunes ils reviendront
si par exemple d'autres territoires elle
devient le territoire demain de la
transition écologique si notre
territoire c'est un territoire où on a
un environnement qui fait qu'il est bon
d'y vivre
mais il ya ce jeu j'y reviens un qui qui
eux ont beaucoup plus de difficultés et
à cela on pense nous qu'il faut qu'ils
aient une solution qu'ils aient un point
d'information d'accueil formation
transition professionnelle a pas moins
de 15 kilomètres de chez eux
je pense que yannick soubien insiste
beaucoup là dessus il était en charge de
la formation professionnelle dont le nom
dans le mandat précédent bassam en vie
il faut faire en sorte que pas un seul
jeune dans notre région se sentent
abandonnés et c'est la responsabilité de
la collectivité beaucoup de travail a
été accomplie il faut continuer dans ce
sens là pour faire en sorte que le droit
à la mobilité le droit à l'accès à
l'éducation aux loisirs culturels à la
formation soit bien garantie pour
l'ensemble des catégories de deux jeunes
dans notre formation je voudrais faire
une dernière remarque sur la question de
l'apprentissage
l'apprentissage et les choses sont dites
mais je pense qu'il faut être précis
discuter de quoi dire de quoi on parle
l'apprentissage se doit pas être une
solution au décrochage scolaire
l'apprentissage pour que ça fonctionne
pour que ça marche que ce soit choisi
faut que ce soit un choix des jeunes il
ya effectivement des apprentissages haut
niveau aux niveaux les plus bas qui sont
parfois difficiles qui sont en baisse on
a vu où on voit aussi que sur les
niveaux les plus élevés ça marche
l'apprentissage l'alternance sa marge
dans les entreprises et donc il ya aussi
un travail qui doit être fait de ce
point de vue là et à mon avis doit
s'éloigner un peu des slogans un peu
généraliste sur l'apprentissage sur le
mode vous en faites pas assez vous en
faites trop je pense qu'il faut faire un
peu de dentelle en la matière
j'entraînerai justement une question
justement sur ceux de l'alternance avec
la pas une question c'est plutôt la vie
d'un internaute jean-yves clients il
conviendrait de prendre plus de mesures
encourageant les entreprises à prendre
des jeunes en alternance en les incitant
à les conserver dans leur effectif à
l'issue de leur formation tout le monde
y gagnerait les jeunes pour l'emploi et
la qualification des entreprises pour la
motivation suscité tout à fait nous
sommes très favorables alternance
première chose il faut aussi assurer et
aider les jeunes donc nous avons un plan
pour que la région puisse intervenir
plus sur la gratuité des transports
existants
mais la question essentielle est quand
même de libérer des places dans le
travail et pour libérer des places dans
le travail il ya deux mesures très
simples
ce thème a parlé tout à l'heure des 32
heures et pourquoi pas mais la retraite
à 60 ans s'il était appliqué
elle nous permettrait quand même dans
notre basse normandie dans notre haute
normandie de libérer des postes de
travail que les jeunes attendent en cdi
après un contrat d'alternance qui permet
effectivement de les former à ce travail
nous avons toute une population nous dit
lord est un département vieux une somme
dans l'ordre eh bien oui mais dans ces
anciens y en a encore de nombreux et
j'en connais beaucoup qui continue à
travailler alors qu'ils ne sont déjà
plus en condition physique pour
travailler alors ouvrons ces emplois aux
jeunes
il ya un potentiel industriel dans
l'ordre très important ouvrons c'est en
projet avec une formation la plus forte
possible la plus riche et la plus longue
possible de façon à ce qu'on me dit
sport aux jeunes au bout de quelques
années d'apprentissage qui ne sont plus
au niveau 2 des technologies pardonnez
moi monsieur chaque les jette un peu
provocateur mais on comprend un peu
mieux pourquoi au niveau national le pc
le ps entendent parce qu'il n'ya que ça
parce que c'est pas quand même la
tendance actuelle on l'a plutôt tendance
à augmenter le temps de travail plutôt
que d'aller vers l'application stricte
la retraite à 60 ans et bien voilà c'est
pour ça que nous sommes en discussion
nous avons deux listes différentes
elle verra après ce qui va se passer
entre les autorités et nicolas calbrix
l'alcool accueil brics dans ce qu'ils ne
savent pas c'est la tête de liste
régionale de debout la france
alors lui aussi il a un point de vue
très très ferme très tranchées sur tout
ce qui concerne la formation d'après lui
il est urgent d'agir pour ne pas dire
réagir
on a besoin de remettre à plat la
formation professionnelle aujourd'hui à
quatorze mille emplois sont non pourvus
dans la région l'industrie aéronautique
n'arrive pas à trouver des cadres est
obligé d'aller chercher en dehors de la
région là qu'on s'assoie avec les
entreprises qu'on s'assoie avec les cci
qu'on remette à plat le plan de
formation de la région qu'on finance ce
qu'on a besoin
je prends mon exemple toujours qui est
moi je suis cadre j'ai une demande une
formation je lai par contre celui qui
est au rsa pour qu'ils aient une
formation c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
il ya 114 mille personnes au rsa
nous on veut que dès janvier 2016 avec
double la france on est une formation
proposée à toutes les personnes et les
rsa pour retourner vers l'emploi est
également lutté un peu contre
l'assistanat
alors qu'on investisse sur les domaines
où l'effort qu'on est des agriculteurs
qu'on ait une vraie stratégie maritime
qu'on fasse de la création d'emplois une
priorité après la formation on va ouvrir
un autre dossier celui de l'aménagement
du territoire comment équilibrer les
forces dans cette future grande
normandie les forces économiques
administratives et politiques
comment vont se répartir des pouvoirs
pour que tous les normands se sentent
concernés n'ont pas oublié philippe
certaines directions déjà reçu la port
d'attache absolument alors on sait que
la préfecture de région selon toute
vraisemblance évidemment ça va être
rouge dit évidemment parce que quand on
a nommé un préfet préfigurateurs on a
compris d'ailleurs le préfet l'a dit
lui-même que on aller dans cette
direction la chambre régionale des
comptes toujours donc à rouen ainsi que
l'environnement l'aménagement et le
logement à caen sait pas c'est pas rien
la rs l' agence régionale de santé la
direction de l'agriculture la drac les
affaires culturelles donc l'institut de
la statistique ou havre le transfert
d'une grande unité interrégional des
douanes la création de l'unité
départementale
du travail alençon alençon dix hommes
une plate forme de traitement des
passeports et puis à cherbourg octeville
la création d'un pôle des métiers
maritimes alors certains disent c'est un
peu de saupoudrage en même temps quelque
part faut pas oublier les territoires et
c'est vrai que d'un point de vue
économique les élus localement à sont
quand même intéressé par ce qui se passe
alors est-ce que c'est suffisant est ce
que ça va aider justement à promouvoir
l'emploi dans certains secteurs c'est
une des questions qu'on peut évoquer et
l'aménagement du territoire c'est vrai
que c'est important
vous allez chez car votre vision sur ce
dossier avec certains même pas que ce
débat se résume au choix de la capitale
pourtant faut bien en parler timothée
houssin comment on répartit les forces
sur le territoire pour soit équilibré
allons-nous depuis le début de cette
campagne on défend une normandie
polycentrique c'est à dire que rouen et
caen se partage d'une part la capitale
régionale et d'autre part la préfecture
de région
on souhaite également que le havre sont
un petit peu la capitale économique
mais on souhaite que toutes les autres
villes de taille importante et moyennes
de la région ne soient pas oubliés on
peut penser à evreux on peut penser à
alençon nous sommes aujourd'hui on peut
penser a berné on peut penser à
cherbourg toutes ces villes doivent
avoir leur place au delà du sujet de la
capitale nous ce qu'on remarque c'est
que dans beaucoup de politiques
publiques ce soit au niveau national ou
au niveau régional on oublie un petit
peu les habitants de la ruralité il voit
peu à peu leurs services publics fermés
ils ont des difficultés à accéder à des
transports publics qui leur permette
d'accéder aux différents bassins
d'emploi on l'évoqué tout à l'heure ils
ont parfois des difficultés aussi à se
déplacer vers telle ou telle formation
qui lui permettrait à leur permettrait
de trouver ou de retrouver un emploi
ils ont aussi des difficultés à accéder
au numérique parfois même au téléphone
nous nous pensons également que la
région doit mener une grande politique
en faveur des personnes de la ruralité
pour assurer un équilibre du territoire
et une égalité entre les normands qu'ils
habitent la plus grande ville où le plus
petit village est ce que vous avez peur
de la métropole rouennaise alors c'est
quelque chose qu'on a entendues dans la
première partie de la campagne pour
prendre un petit peu moins maintenant
mais c'est vrai que dans certains cas il
se sent chaise le président de la maison
paul roanne elle dit c'est très bien
parce que cette métropole déjà il ya
beaucoup d'emplois et vendre native et
d'un massage non mais ce qui est
dramatique dans cette question c'est
tout d'abord que ces métropoles
et puis les nouvelles communautés de
communes qui maintenant 2
avoir vingt mille habitants on voit des
communautés de communes qui se font
interdépartemental monde donc c'est le
choix de l'ump et du ps ils sont en
train de casser les départements au
profit de grandes régions et de
métropole avec des grandes régions qui
parfois ils ont négocié directement
certaines choses avec bruxelles nous
nous sommes pour la défense du
département et de l'échelon national
donc nous y sommes plutôt opposés et
puis ces grandes métropoles elle
j'oublie les habitants de la ruralité
comme on vient de le dire qui encore une
fois vont être délaissés dépôt des
politiques publiques
on va concentrer les richesses sur les
métropoles et on va avoir des déserts en
termes de médecins de numérique
d'emplois dans les zones rurales où on
trouve ça regrettable et on défend avant
tout mais aussi les habitants de la
ruralité
on peut faire un éclairage juste sur le
haut débit à un kart commandé par la
commission européenne qui montre que 65%
des français n'ont pas accès haut débit
ce sont les fameuses zones blanches la
france est largement distancé par les
pays baltes l'islande l'irlande du nord
et même l'espagne le calvados à une
couverture comprise entre 35 et 65 %
les quatre autres départements normands
ont une couverture entre 0 et 35 %
sophie gaugain je crois que le sujet de
l'aménagement du territoire et centrale
d'abord parce qui rejoint aussi le
premier celui du développement
économique et que c'est très important
et qu'une normandie réunifiée réussi
c'est une normandie partagée et que
c'est pas du tout un débat stérile et
d'arrière-garde que de se poser ces
questions-là qu'effectivement corrompt
le havre sont importants et que
travailler par paul ça fait aussi partie
de la nouvelle carte et d'aménagement du
territoire avec tout ce tissu de villes
moyennes et qui fait particulièrement
les sens alors chez nous encore plus en
basse normandie mais qu'il faudra
fédérer autour de projets structurants
et je crois que c'est passionnant
d'organiser ce nouveau territoire en
complémentarité évidemment le monde
rural il a suffisamment souffert et je
crois que le fait que ce que nous
proposons dans la normandie conquérante
avec 1 rue morin ces deux rues
contractualiser directement avec les
communautés de communes par le biais
aussi des fonds européens qui seront
amenés aux régions c'est très important
et le débat alors vous parlez de capital
mais c'est pas exactement ça c'est l'
équilibre entre l'installation de la
préfecture est le siège du conseil
régional dès le début et depuis deux ans
nous
10 puisque nous sommes conseillers
régionaux sortants les républicains et
le centre que nous voulions un équilibre
et que le siège du conseil régional les
services afférents à la région et son
organisation devait être à rouen il me
semble que parfois il faut aussi prendre
en compte l'histoire
guillaume le conquérant s'était pas
trompé en créant des équilibres entre
les deux rives de la seine et nous
devrions nous en inspirer pour que
chaque territoire se sont investis et
derrière c'est quoi si c'est pas ce qui
se passe et ce sera la responsabilité de
chacun des conseillers régionaux
c'est pour ça que dès le 18 juin nous
avions proposé un voeu que personne n'a
voulu adopter au conseil régional de
basse-normandie les républicains et les
centristes ont déposé en étant très
clair en disant nous c'est aujourd'hui
que nous voulons décider et envoyer un
signe à cons parce que derrière on se
bagarre pas pour se bagarrer et
d'ailleurs les chefs d'entreprise du
collectif nous sommes guillaume l'ont
bien compris
c'est parce que c'est l'appel d'air qui
va derrière ce sont le siège de
fédération les seiches d'entreprise qui
auront tendance à vouloir aller vers moi
et je crois que la basse normandie n'a
pas besoin de cela
et qu'aujourd'hui on doit être soudé
derrière cet enjeu primordial qui est
pas un enjeu de c'est qui le plus fort
et on s'oppose au contraire c'est
comment on réussi ensemble et comment on
défend déséquilibre parce que derrière
je mesure l'appel d'air et il suffit
d'en parler avec certaines fédérations
ou professionnels ou sportifs pour voir
les inquiétudes leurs mauvais sur ce
dossier effectivement de l' équilibre
des pouvoirs à des directions et la
politique d'aménagement des territoires
ne se résume pas à la répartition c'est
pas un jeu de monopoly je prends ce cas
je l'installé c'est une logique beaucoup
plus fortes de soutien à tous les
territoires pour leur donner la place
posez la question au sud de la manche au
sud du perche ces questions-là leur sont
un petit peu étrangère il faut que nous
organisions le développement de tous les
pays de tous les territoires de cette
normandie autour d'une problématique qui
laisse la place à chacun on n'oppose pas
le monde rural à roy s'est complètement
factice
on ne met pas en avant les risques d'une
métropole c'est une chance une métropole
toutes les régions ont des métropoles
par contre il faut apporter des
dispositifs par exemple nous proposons
pour l'orne ce département qu'un que
qu'hervé morin a conspué en le traitant
de tous les noms
nous apportons un projet un contrat pour
investir sur ce que ces départements a
besoin indifféremment des problématiques
de répartition des sièges d un d
administration d autres il faut agir
investir sur les leviers du
développement et le faire de façon
adaptée par tous à condition ça se
prépare
parce que à l'heure où nous parlons
aujourd'hui cette grande réunification
monsieur beauvais dit il faut bon il
aurait pu pendant dix ans avec son
successeur
particulièrement pour l'heure nous nous
avons avec bertrand zone union invention
de développement avec leurs rangs
d'oignons nous avons inscrit un doublé
sur la nécessité de l'enclavé ce
territoire et c'est l'engagement que
nous prenons avec la rn 12 est
particulièrement jeudi il faut que ça se
prépare
alors aujourd'hui rien n'est préparé et
il suffit d'aller échanger avec les
chefs d'entreprises le monde économique
est les branches professionnelles pour
saisir sur le terrain cette inquiétude
est monsieur beauvais vous l'avez
entendu dans toutes les réunions
publiques que nous avons fait partout
dans tous les départements
cette question a été posée donc
l'urgence à avoir une vraie politique
structuré et d'aménagement du territoire
est majeur des élections faisant peur
aux autres c'est pas comme ça que c'est
noir six ans la réalité nous avons
préparé pour le power knee on va
continuer vous aurez alors le premier
engagement parce que vous collez
d'europe écologie les verts ne veulent
aucun des enclaves la longue la loi
notre nouvelle organisation territoriale
pour ceux qui ont quitté leur apparente
c'est vrai que c'est pas obligatoirement
faciles
monsieur châtelet finalement cette loi
notre elle a fait jeudi un pas la part
belle mais elle a préservé les
départements en disant on fait des
grandes régions dont pour garder de la
proximité et là on parlait des zones
rurales c'est vrai que les départements
ont tous leur rôle à jouer ou parti
communiste en particulier mais offrant
gauche en général vous avez plutôt
défendu cette tendance donc à votre avis
que l'organisation territoriale comme
disait monsieur mauvais c'est tous les
territoires ensemble en fonction des
différentes prérogatives tout à fait
c'est tous les territoires ensemble et
nous avons nous une mesure
nous voudrions prendre dès le début du
prochain la prochaine mandature
c'est de créer un moratoire sur le
service public parce que je crois que le
président de région a raison c'est tous
les territoires qu'il faut regarder mais
dans leur équilibre global puisque nous
n'avons pas par exemple la
responsabilité sur la santé or la santé
est un élément essentiel de valoriser
des déserts médicaux
alors qu'il y à des déserts médicaux
nous y travaillons sur les déserts
médicaux
mais je pense notamment pour l'ex
territoire basse normandie qui va donc
devenir normand parce que je ne serai
pas conservateur au point de garder le
terme basse normandie mais dans les
hôpitaux qui sont sur ces trois
territoires
il y à des difficultés importantes or la
région doit se pencher ferrat moratoire
et discuter avec les populations de
façon à assurer l'ensemble des problèmes
médicaux c'est pour nous un point
extrêmement important et malheureusement
la loi notre un défaut fondamental c'est
celui d'organiser la concurrence des
territoires et c'est aux nouveaux
conseils régionaux justement de voir et
d'affiner pour qu'on ne soit pas avec
des territoires en concurrence mais en
coopération entre les villes moyennes
les villes principales etc
ça se travaille c'est déjà travaillé
pour la partie basse normandie je
connais moins la haute normandie mais je
suis sûr que mes collègues qui ont déjà
travaillé et ça va être le but de du
début de notre mandature d'équilibré
tous ces territoires d'imaginer une
nouvelle normandie
on travaille en complémentarité
attention les ténèbres oui je pense que
c'est il ya un enjeu d'égalité des
territoires qui est qui est évident mais
je pense que à un peu loin de sa nombre
de présentations qui me semblent
caricatural on est on a particulièrement
chanceux dans nos grandes régions
normand va je crois qu'on a la chance
d'avoir les trois grandes villes
y compris la métropole qu'on a la chance
d'avoir un réseau maillé de villes
petites et moyennes qui rendent nos
territoires résilient crois qu'en cas de
difficultés en période de crise c'est un
atout extrêmement important et puis il
faut quand même mais connaître ou
peut-être mépriser les territoires
ruraux pour les réduire à ce qu'on a dit
non les territoires une rolls ya la
richesse si l innovation il ya
l'initiative
moi j'étais en charge des fonds
européens dans ce mandat je peux vous
assurer qu on est en train de regarder
les candidats qui répondent au pro am
leader qui sont des projets beau temps
global des projets du terrain des élus
locaux des sociétés civiles locales des
associations locales des entreprises
locales qui présente des actions des
propositions d'action des projets
collectifs ça ça existe aussi dans nos
territoires ruraux la normandie
aujourd'hui ces 13 pays ont notamment 10
13 pays en basse-normandie si je ne me
trompe 26 pays et autant de territoires
de projets autant de gens qui ont
l'habitude de coopérer pour se
développer pour agir pour innover pour
de manière durable plus sain parce que
en effet ça vient du terrain et la
préoccupation en général principal des
initiateurs de ces projets là c'est le
développement d'activités et d'emplois
locaux donc tout ça c'est plutôt des
atouts et moi je partage pas une
présentation qui est un peu le sinistre
est caricatural de notre territoire je
crois au contraire qu'on a une chance
d'avoir un territoire équilibré qu'il
faut bien surveiller à cet équilibre
il faut bien sûr garantir l'égalité des
territoires il faut bien sûr comme
yannick soubien me disent souvent faire
en sorte que les à chaque habitant
quelques outils soient dans le
territoire aient accès à moins de 15
kilomètres à une réponse quand il ya un
besoin quand il a besoin de rencontrer
la collectivité tout ça doit être mis en
place et je pense qu'on a beaucoup
d'atouts pour y arriver
justement on va parler des transports
une grande normandie de presque trente
mille kilomètres carrés cinq
départements 3221 commune comment vont
circuler les normands dans la région et
vers paris l'épineux dossier du train
l'éclairage tout de suite avec magali
nicolin en 2014 près de 6 millions de
voyageurs ont emprunté la ligne paris
rouen le havre 24 aller retour de trains
intercités sont programmées chaque jour
sur cette ligne ou la sncf prévoit
d'investir 375 millions d'euros d'ici
2020 l'an passé toujours 4 millions de
personnes ont voyagé sur la ligne paris
caen cherbourg qui propose treize
liaisons quotidiennes
là aussi des investis
à hauteur de 235 millions d'euros sont
planifiés tout comme sur la ligne paris
granville emprunté par huit cent mille
voyageurs annuels et qui bénéficiera de
200 millions d'euros d'ici cinq ans le
plus gros financeur de ces travaux est à
chaque fois la région devant l'état et
la sncf
autre chantier de grande ampleur sous la
houlette cette fois de réseau ferré de
france c'est la ligne nouvelle
paris-normandie
son but réduire les temps de parcours
le projet en est encore à l'état d'étude
jusqu'en 2016
il s'agit de définir le tracé final
l'une des difficultés réside dans le
passage de la zone urbaine déjà très
dense de mantes la jolie
à ce jour le coût de cet immense
chantier est compris entre 9 et 13
milliards d'euros son financement n'est
pas arrêté les usagers normand déjà fort
mécontent devront de toute façon faire
preuve de patience
la mise en service ne devrait pas
intervenir avant 2025 alors mauvais d&g
normand patients c'est un petit peu
presque obligatoire
je dirais celle d'une nouvelle est ce
qu'elle doit aller jusqu'au bout vous y
croyez ou est-ce qu'il faut se contenter
déjà des millions d'euros investis pour
pour préserver l'existant mais à lire
existe un virage jusqu'au bout elle est
programmée dans un temps l'eau parce que
vous avez entendu ces chiffres 2
milliards et les grandes lignes tgv on y
20 ans pour apparaître à la elle se fera
aujourd'hui notre responsabilité c'est
d'améliorer les trains du quotidien 1 et
la région basse normandie la région
haute-normandie le fond et avec nicolas
mayer rossignol
la réunion des deux régions permettra de
mener cette bataille du rail dans des
conditions encore plus forte qu'il faut
se battre
ce que nous faisons depuis des jours et
des jours depuis le début de ce mandat
pour améliorer les choses et les
investissements que nous avons réalisés
sur paris granville sont le témoin de
notre capacité à continuer sur cette
ligne de paris caen cherbourg mais aussi
paris rouen le havre pour les trains
aujourd'hui demain on le prépare
aujourd'hui nous agissons pour améliorer
les choses on ne parle pas du ter des
trains express régionaux dont nous avons
la responsabilité qu'il fonctionne bien
les bilans sont là les usagers de 10 ce
sont des grandes
qu'ils appartiennent à l'état qui sont
de la responsabilité nationale sur
lesquels il faut mener cette bataille il
faut abandonner pour vous la ligne
nouvelle paris normandie et privilégier
les transports à l'intérieur de la
normandie
oui moi quand je me déplace dans l'eure
et que je rencontre les différents
usagers du train qui se déplacent
notamment en région parisienne
ils vont travailler tous les matins et
ils n'ont pas envie d'attendre 2035 pour
des solutions à leurs problèmes
par ailleurs mulliez qui coûte 13
milliards d'euros nous nous pensions
qu'elle va phagocyter l'ensemble des
fonds que nous utilisons notamment pour
les transports et que donc vont être
encore une fois abandonné un certain
nombre d'autres lignes et notamment
toutes celles qui concernent encore une
fois la ruralité
nous pensons qu'il ya un certain nombre
d'aménagements à faire pour couper les
gouttes double de bréval ou de bréauté
et gagner du temps il faudrait également
en faire un nouveau tronçon entre la
londe et sert que pour rapprocher rouen
et caen les mettre à l'honneur l'un de
l'autre
il faudrait ouvrir une ligne entre
elbeuf ville et la ligne le neubourg
evreux afin de rapprocher evreux et
rouen qu'on mette à peu près 45 minutes
pour y aller et non une heure cinquante
comme c'est le cas actuellement avec
personne ne prend le train pour aller
d'evreux à rouen
tout ça c'est possible mais il faut que
ça soit l'une des priorités plutôt que
de financer une lnpn dont on ne connaît
absolument pas les délais et qui a un
coût exorbitant qui fera notamment
probablement augmenter fortement le prix
du billet de train alors que les
transports en commun sont aussi beaucoup
utilisé par les normands qui ont le
moins de moyens alors le train ce n'est
pas toujours facile on va pas parler de
la ligne bordeaux-paris on pourrait fait
pas dans la région il est bon que pour
le moment ce top le financement parce
que bell et les partenaires ne participe
pas comme il le souhaiterait c'est plus
près de nous le pays de bray vient de
rejeter la ligne ferroviaire de fret
serqueux gisors je sais pas si vous êtes
au courant mais c'est au sein et puis
votre chef de file dans la région et
madame gauguin donc je prends le
monsieur brown alors lui ce qu'il veut
toujours dans le cadre de l'aménagement
du territoire c'est rendre les liaisons
entre caen et rouen ont parlé tout à
l'heure justement de la façon de
travailler le mieux possible avec les
deux capitales actuel de la haute et de
la basse normandie dans le cadre d'une
normandie réunifiée avec un cadencement
beaucoup plus important des trains plus
confortable et c'est alors certains je
dis pas que ça les fait rire mais il
trouve que c'est une idée quand même un
petit peu
on va dire un petit peu osé alors c'est
quoi votre point de vue est ce que votre
avis c'est possible il ya différents
sujets si je peux revenir sur sur la lgv
c'est évident qu'il va falloir peser
avec auprès de la sncf parce qu'on ne
peut pas se passer lorsque le sait bien
on dans la ligue la nouvelle n'avait pas
une amende
on ne peut on ne peut pas se passer de
cet outil pour le désenclavement cette
région et particulièrement en termes de
développement économique
après on ne peut pas attendre
indéfiniment non plus donc je crois
qu'il dans l'intermédiaire il faudra et
c'est ce que propose hervé morin dans
son plan pour le rail investir à ce
sujet là pour moderniser pour cadencer
pour accélérer le rythme la navette caen
rouen il faut se poser la question et
s'est pas complètement inédit de se dire
qu'il va falloir justement favoriser les
échanges
ça fait partie du débat il ya d'autres
aussi moyen heureusement qu'ils vont
nous permettre de travailler aujourd'hui
et ce n'est pas parce que il ya cette
bipolarité
nous souhaitons dans le futur projet que
ces trajets ça fait partie de la vie des
gens quand vous voyez les arrivées sur
les périphériques canet et ça c'est un
projet que nous proposons très
clairement dans la partie normande c'est
qu'on travaille sur ce projet là et en
périphérie de rouen les contrats de plan
état région alors qu'ils sont déjà
enclenchées mais qui devront être revus
semble-t-il doivent permettre une plus
grande fluidité routière mais en même
temps on doit aller soulagé par cette
navette
quand roy moi je voudrais quand même
vous donner une inquiétude parce que
quels que soient les partis politiques
confondus on aura les questions et des
difficultés me semble-t-il parce que le
plan pour le bus mis en place par la loi
macron ça fait des voyageurs en moins
dans les trains et quand on viendra
défendre des lignes ou des arrêts et
c'est le cas particulièrement dans
l'orne et bien on va nous dire mais
vous êtes gentil tout ce que vous en
êtes mesdames et messieurs les
conseillers régionaux mais regardez il
ya moins de voyageurs dans le train et
donc je ne suis pas sûr que cette idée
qui peut être au départ bien senties
favorise le train dans notre région
normande dont les usagers ont énormément
besoin particulièrement pour travailler
et pour la jeunesse on sait qu'il ya un
bus macro qui va s'arrêter à briouze
il fait rigoler je veux pas raconter
n'importe quoi je ne vais pas raconter
n'importe quoi faut pas faire peur aux
gens avaient investi 150 millions sur la
ligne a et qu'on vit aujourd'hui des
trains sont là les investissements se
réalise
les gars se modernise c'est du concret
ça c'est pas engagement que nous avons
pris on est capable de le faire parce
qu'on a agi dans notre bilan déjà
surnommé d'occasion annoncé six ans
leila ipn les normands l'attendent
encore vous l'aviez annoncé ya six ans
beaucoup les bus c'est parce que pour le
même trajet ils sont beaucoup moins
chers que les trains donc nous on pense
pas que la lnpn qui va faire gagner
quelques minutes mais qui va coûter
beaucoup plus cher soit la solution
les gens cherchent à gagner un petit peu
tôt mais gagne surtout est-ce que c'est
moins cher quand on a besoin de
débloquer beaucoup de bus pour desservir
la ruralité il ya aussi énormément de
gens qui habitent pas à côté d'une gare
il faut quitter un transport en commun
pour aller à la gare et là on a besoin
de ces buses ou à l'excellence la
compétence des régions sur les
transports collectifs comme la france et
là on va pouvoir voir une politique
d'intermodalité qui va être très forte
il faut qu'ils permettent de travailler
aux abords des gares ça fait partie des
aménagements
je suis tellement fière de l'impasse sur
ce mélange et écoutez c'est pas un petit
break qui re qui rejette la liaison
serre que c'est le maire ump de gournay
et je vous rappelle quand même que ses
liaisons frac est fondamental qui est
fondamental si on se préoccupe de savoir
comment on évacue les caisses du pendu à
la ligne serqueux gisors je vous assure
elle est très important il est très très
important moi aussi je pense qu'il faut
quand même être un petit peu un petit
peu sérieux quand on parle de ces choses
là
vous savez les écologistes depuis le
début je crois que pourra nous rendre le
fait que sur la liste des liaisons
elle édite lnpn aujourd'hui on était sur
une position très très raisonnable
traîne mesurait très pragmatique qui
consistait à dire faisons ce qu'on sait
faire et ce qu'on peut financer et en
l'occurrence on y arrive c'est
l'amélioration c'est la gare de rouen la
feuillie pas qu'il s'attaque lui dit est
indispensable pour la totalité du
territoire normand et c'est le monde
fois on y est après il ya ce sujet
millions d'euros oui c'est donc
finançables ses finances et j'ai envie
de dire et c'est pas aux calendes
grecques contrairement à ce qu est ce qu
on dise quand j'entends ici et puis
enfin il faut améliorer les services
parce que c'est pas adapté à notre
époque qu'aujourd'hui les gens qui
travaillent continue à vivre le stress
du dernier train avec le stress du
dernier trajet dernier les transports en
commun donc il faut travailler sur la
qualité du service sur l'amplitude
horaire des services que le transport de
ter ont des transports urbains
il faut travailler sur l'intermodalité
avec les services de cartes de ce point
de vue là comme les régions vont devenir
effectivement responsable des quarts des
parties service de cars départementaux
et une aussi des cars scolaires
je le dis parce que le car scolaire je
pense qu'on peut s'améliorer parce que
les cars scolaires ils sont treize
régions en avant l'accord une partie du
temps et je pense qu'il va changer t il
ya des choses intelligentes à regarder
la gratuité pour les enfants
la gratuité pour les enfants mais aussi
peut-être plus important d'utilisation
des cartes scolaires et ce alors qu'il
reviendra vite peut-être ils pourraient
rationner se réfléchit un petit peut
servir à faire du rabattement vers les
trains pu faire du rabattement vers
d'autres modes de transport collectifs
donc voilà c'est le couvert à cette
question là pour nous son analyse eu un
dirigeant est très importante
jean chatelais puisqu'il faut équilibrer
les temps de parole ou rejeter une
question d'alban du havre que proposent
les différents candidats pour améliorer
les liaisons ferroviaires en normandie
la ligne paris caen cherbourg est une
aventure pas de tgv quand paris ou le
havre rouen paris
comment se déplacer rapidement entre les
villes normandes sont les voitures à
bien l'écouter
très rapidement il suffit de confier
aux élus régionaux héros des moyens
financiers qui leur permettent
effectivement faut-il prendre en charge
la base de l'état délits qui sont
ressort de l'état je ne pense pas et en
tout cas si on devait les prendre comme
semble l'annoncer le plan du rond qui
n'est pas un plan que nous souhaitons si
on devait s'en aller dans ses
orientations là il nous faut les moyens
financiers de l'état pour le faire nous
savons le faire
40% ter en + 40 % de clients du tr en
plus sur ce dernier mandat
nous savons le faire mais encore
faudrait-il que ce soit notre mission ce
n'est pas encore notre mission et je
suis aussi très très très très amer sur
les histoires de bus
nous avons des trains qui desservent
hollande nous avons une inquiétude sur
la ligne caen tours qui pourraient être
liés de fret aussi pour sortir les
conteneurs du havre qui irait vers le
centre de la france nous devons nous
battre et nous l'avons fait pendant ses
deux mandats avec le président de région
avec nos amis d'europe écologie les
verts
nous allons continuer dans le prochain
mandat renouvelable sur ces questions
qui sont essentiels pour les habitants
de notre grande région normande
merci merci à vous d'être venus débattre
pour parler économie aménagement du
territoire et de transport le débat du
samedi 14 décembre dans la voile il n'a
pas été diffusé il avait été enregistrée
la veille
le 13 novembre à la cité de la mer de
châbons nous avions parlé d'économie de
la mer à cause des attentats bien sûr à
cette émission n'a pas été diffusée vous
pourrez la suivre sur notre antenne
demain à 11h prochain rendez vous
politique un débat entre les principaux
candidats mercredi 2 décembre à partir
de 22h50
une émission présentée par emilie
lecomte et franck besnier très bon
week-end à vous au revoir
là